Jason told me to do it I'll catch em
taxidermy drunken truth Toki if you like
the Sam Raimi camera
there's a monster out here what is it
we're talking nards sorry
so are we actually talking guards are we
talking about NARS we're done we're
talking up about nards I'm just talking
yeah what the hell yeah we're actually
nerds that is that a penis
you're way out here wait wait what are
ours
wait wait what what is nards balls
that's nach no it was NARS
okay all right you lived through the 80s
yeah I didn't have any bowls in okay all
right that's what marriage does to you
yeah you know I got it building this but
not our quote like talk about Wolverine
and madness man uber keep talking yeah
Nell store key talk head well okay they
did Turkey medic Jamel I will say this
for the record though as much as I liked
it when I was younger rewatching into
Turtles it's terrible oh it sucks yummy
I love it but it's some stupid cartoon -
always thought it was terrible your
comment it's what is Ninja Turtles ah
turtles live or die woman they're -
mutant oh my god this is my your another
club oh nice
you're the puns like it's meant to be
just joking
no I'm talking about just like even the
animation even just everything about
this is terrible that's crazy
so that means it can be crap you know
the Challenger just exploded one morning
a ninja turn to the world any day when
I'm in the classroom watching that live
on TV
and I was so excited cuz I did actually
want to be an astronaut hello
after that I was like I started actually
crying I was that traumatised just
devastated and I wanted joy I'm like
Doug do not want it being slightly
delayed ever again and after that you
always want to be a ninja turtle
possibly yes a rebuttal to the head
today it's a ninja turn as a people as a
nation one nation under splinter I want
to show Mozart on the side of the
shredder a nation under Krang it's like
I want conquer the world
piffle robot a shredder I'm gonna tell
you generally do a tentacle it's okay
it's gosh uh it's uh we're gonna show
the camera on you it's a person get a
GUI you just go smashing perfect Rick
yes friggin optical I only now I know
you said it was good how about a water
sure knowledge on gun that's a good look
that the villains right here but no
again Malcolm Malcolm hair economical
all right are you sure
oh snap Wow really oh yeah oh snap can
we be more nanorack Elevens hop yes yeah
gonna get back to the river before
crackle oh no I'm not gonna get every
comics Nixon
collision this Clinton's in do yeah I
think we could just have your What's My
Line I won't give you
yeah yeah terrific terrific Clint Clint
on klitz off yeah yeah that's really
thinking
Trevor who's a gang sent herself okay
yeah
what's up good yeah what's the gang sign
for Southside there's no there's East
last oh no okay do again Bloods and
Crips hello I was in both I believe it
to be a lie of sorry too
actually my school photos in the
students disciples because of a special
emotions t-shirt what s P but it looked
like a D so that I wasn't sitting still
wow yeah
sad isn't it the other side talking
alright oh yeah that's true continuity
well I mean oh yeah we can probably
matters considering I mean this was
supposed to be like all your hands went
invite not even existed even have even
more hilarious about some other side a
totally out of cat so yeah that's right
I just have a muppet and assistant um
you know we gonna play as well yeah
actually a lot Aaron
uh we're gonna have you be aa bigger yes
flying Buffalo bison advicing I think I
read a keep your hand actually out of it
so see you just go like down you want
the Twinkie open or closed covers handed
hits if it's open is gonna get a little
messy chocolatey well do one close and
we'll try one of it I'm trying to be
nice it looks like a turd if it's open
now got more than don't have it half
open
put your hands in together so I can see
where the center smashes yeah I'll go
first then Jim Malcolm also we're going
in a circle
yeah we trying to chew it should we do
that I get more than just all over again
seems like all of our heads twice I
don't guess I'm gonna hit the tire you
know like you two can chew you know go
over it uh you know we can do is just as
like a gag one baby but this first one
we'll do like you know I'll go in up
and then we'll do another one where we
do the other hand as well so okay one
open or closed closed on this one we'll
do it okay
I put your hand in the center died oh
except we're joke ahem Malcolm here as
well where we're just gonna put him in
later so he's gonna be up against the
wall just try to get enjoying the cream
some more okay like did you get all of
us in the yeah okay yeah so get often in
this all right
- Malcolm in this way you're gonna be
the oh we did a group picture earlier
not and we're just gonna cat Photoshop
you as would be the case in real 80s
medicine here isn't it so pretty much I
we're all doing like the cliche cross on
the calculator like he's having a snack
and like Jim's like you know doing like
this with the shades looks like us up
okay you can do it yeah this is a
picture Oh God
wait let me focus Wow how'd you Jason in
his normal garb
Shirah it is I said - normally hello oh
wow I didn't have to photoshop there's
no normally where is it honey - Rihanna
KKK outfit Nazi uniform I mean come on I
need hi why cuz you're on a nice comfy
couch
no no because we're talking about her
placement
everybody's gonna be watching The
Adventure Time nuance outgoing Colin
knew it all along
why are you filming me
you're exciting are you feeling me
Hongki did you bring a confederate yeah
talking about bringing the sheets oh
that's still my favorite South Park once
the first Halloween one working our
address is aborted slow what are you
doing I'm a ghost
I might have to start watching south
park' yes what if I was in original
school okay first season I know I might
have been more years old but yeah was he
racist in the beginning he didn't know
it's what his mom would always say my
mom says there's a lot of brown people
in Africa it wasn't like races to be it
is true that yeah like they don't turn
he gets like worse and worse right there
yeah I mean he's like just basically a
me Oh nuts
yeah well I should talk about what this
is for behind the sea I just discovered
this joke gravity falls and oh it gets
hilarious and amazing so when we have
the ancient book of ancientness because
every 80s boy group team has like this
aging book to look at some kind of cult
book uh and is this actually a Bible
what's this yeah what what did you know
so now I go got Watson the kids going
okay what is that character the triangle
the tall long-legged blood and I know
it's so that she was facing the driver
her fingers gently touched the bier so
he's showing on his upper jaw and then
moved to trace his ear and when he
jumped involuntarily she laughed softly
I learned that from my husband mrs.
Caroline ward Mack McNair ax of
Jenkintown Pennsylvania said to Captain
Charles and Galway Lily's er coz home of
record was Co headquarters USMC
Washington DC is such a convoluted
well it's then we got chapter 5 the
Andrew foster Hotel San Francisco
California 22 June 1942 ok exam I'm not
exaggerating look interesting hey yes
that would be the greatest porno ever I
learned that from my husband mrs.
Caroline ward McNamara of Jenkintown
Pennsylvania said the captain Charles
I'm Galloway USMC our who's a record
with Co headquarters USMC Washington DC
well and now mrs. McNamara was wearing a
pleated plaid skirt a sweater a string
of pearls and a little makeup
all of which tended to make it look
younger than her 33 years
captain Galloway who was wearing a fur
collar horsehair and leather jacket
known to the supply department of the US
Navy as jacket fliers intermediate
time GI over at Alice khaki shirt was 25
smashing in so much character
development in a sentence she's ever
been word smashing that's not Asian
that's not even character development
it's just a description right archer
where archers moms trying to write the
movie a little bit yeah that's mandingo
to let songs called mandingo to mother
mother raising Lana
Dada the mustache is surprisingly
matching your hair like time to get are
you do what you gonna do Rob sexy right
right ed yep hey Rob yep
and action good let me do it again yeah
I say start moving a little yeah okay
ready rub yep pretty dead yep and action
good yeah yeah tell me wanting those
shotgun
mmm action good oh yeah
the president's down he's down like a
superior film uh yeah Jim maybe you can
uh you seem good yes animal like sheep
yeah let me get out the way yeah gonna
do a little nod when you're like just
right so who's writing the eighties run
tosh.o ended I'm sure that's on my
musical
Haga they have a long like corny duh dad
I need a mom oh ho hold the sword where
you have a fourth gonna be it on fast
and it's gonna be full of a bunch of
shots come on Josh another super
Christmas cretin
okay that the magic work okay I don't
know that much actually multicultural
can we have him like this go right in
there and say multi oh oh yeah we can
try this like are you how did you hold
the sword like this because
multi-culture gonna do it okay Howie did
I let you bite it so don't fight it it's
funnier just over that broom man we do
whatever a kid Ebola
something about Ebola yeah and actually
and you did Jamison Ebola it's like me
having catch feelings green-screen him
in so he pops up just below evil Jason
what is wrong with him
yeah Oh are we doing up with him there's
like having no shame and just having no
sense true there's a huge difference
is it possible look if I can see this
way you two have our it's like alpha
turns that is all
skipper's only have the light yeah oh
yeah I bet I'm also getting paid 30%
less
- oh no it's 40%
oh just you should be you should be
lucky he's not getting paid anything oh
this is a paint job we owe me payment
Fonzie cigarettes yeah I'm pretty good
so they're 35 years whatever you light
it up it goes hey it burns like this
you're gonna go up to the door and go to
the door and say my calculations are
correct there's a simpler way around
this I'll be gender we can't understand
your science mumbo-jumbo man speak
English but sympathy is we walk the door
then you push the okay then Bing that's
Walker bros ikeda easy bros before hos
hi actually I think hos I never
understood enema and I think sometimes
hos me p.m. first episode no oh okay
it's pretty way to visit a recent wonder
no well I haven't seen the new season I
heard the new seasons pretty poor I
haven't seen yet so no it's the one
after I forgot his name the rapper its
found out to be gay gosh it's not like
public knowledge but it's basically a
song basically bros before hoes
oh yeah you're an awesome family that's
a full car Oh stabilize at least you
know no guy hits boobs yeah you'd be
pretty pretty decent someday why do you
still agree with the guys I'd want to be
with the girls home with you I was just
talking about the faggots
I'm fine with the boylan how some women
see it Priscilla hey twice oh hey uh
Taylor go ahead and get in the cowboy
outfit adjust the adjust this shirt are
you guys need the Hat early instead
slowly she's in that cowboy oh it's
gonna be one of those every day here one
of those days in its Moops a day Peevy
standing up against buckle right I want
to go back to JC in the wheeled warriors
yes which was never had never finished
true I thought was the coolest show
because this character's name was Jason
like what like speaking yeah I'm just
like I thank you I'm gonna turn this
into a documentary back when Saturday
morning errands okay no worries when
basically guys in like giant vehicles
with buzz saws and stuff and they were
going against the bad guys that were
like plantlife numerable you're all
gonna be now so I like stuff you were
watching when you were ten I was still
five so we had like well it was a
distance but there as well yeah we have
like pound puppies I watched pound
puppies with cooler and whopper and
Maria and bright eyes and I don't I saw
I saw
pound puppies on DVD I was like oh my
god it's the new one yeah that's on
YouTube okay I uh obviously the Real
Ghostbusters oh no that fucking amazing
oh that was holes that was interesting
two tons of bone wrapped up and rolled
up in well actually that was one of my
favorites with Robot Chicken yeah how
did you give it together it's the horse
in the B oh my god oh my god they're
talking to each other live in W right
was yep I'm blind
yeah they're talking about how they got
to go oh that's funny and that free day
got me here is that was like yes
Disney I think venom would even help me
oh yeah why don't we just I didn't know
that yeah the puzzles oh my favorite
that was all uh and probably the Popples
I loved the Popples I remember watching
the potholes much I remember I remember
house I remember elf tails oh my god
that was yeah I love my fen Xiang - I
know
so catchy was Snorks maybe scoffs no TV
okay see it like they show okay Mitchell
sponge you remember the Happy Days
cartoon yes there's a Happy Days yes
there's a really good time with a
cartoon for Logan's planet you can see
planet yeah Gilligan's diaper which one
foofer food snow kids I remember one Oh
God that was weird
Elsa we can't inque right and then uh
yeah in the 90s they came out with Tom
and Jerry kids yes so so yeah yeah no we
don't speak of that yeah we had SWAT
Kats got SWAT wait Roadhouse the for
movie so yeah I remember that one the
tick of course Oh take my car Mike's
biker mice from ours
that was fun Silverhawks so close the
Roswell silver burn Thundercats ho is
that so long as it's not gonna break
stars bring star stars bring
we're right back the eighties this is 72
eighties and nineties yeah I'm trying to
go 90s but you guys want to go back
further I'm just like darling surprise
these weirdos everyone it just need to
get this like you know I'm gonna nurture
this moment of pain for you
secret I'm gonna nurture this moment of
pain for you Shh good now see the
panties are wet
Pena's are so late you could read a
child him Oh
from Archer so she did help them out
didn't she
yeah kind of feeling bad how we got
about Tamara yeah don't even remember
every day yeah yeah yeah was your need
you know it affected me so deeply I have
to just go quiet okay that should have
been more supportive like the great
heroes robert e lee and John looks booth
hey I have an idea
how about yeah
runs in the family I got one take he
fucked it up for my eyes yeah yeah kind
of feeling bad for how we treated Tamara
earlier yeah bogus balls we should have
been more supportive like our heroes
John Wilkes Booth and robert e lee it
was Malcolm I said that just killed
locust ball
I kept it together right after ISA
bogeys fall semester
oh and action
so yeah kind of won't bad how we treated
Tamra earlier yeah
bogus balls we should have been more
supportive like our heroes Robert elene
John Wilkes Booth you know I am an idea
how about we let the first girl we see
next join which according to my
calculation should be for a particular
bit recording to my calculations should
be right about that so hard
it is therefore it was that first time
he said balls of it at the reservoirs
yes focus how do when I'll argue it
isn't pretty fucking juvenile we lock
the door up Tarson and one two three
yeah I you might want to back after he
said that night oh yeah I'm sorry hey
ready and action
do I start you should I'm sorry yeah
like it's amazing the 80s even allowed
this out of its decades stupid no just a
little stop there we'll do it good
I feel so bad actually saying this I
know I got you're the same way it feels
weird saying it like everything you're
so does the reality mods no I know but
oh my god hey I know I do on the same
way I love the movie - doesn't mean
you're right don't feel right I hate you
that's what reality does it shows us
that it's probably just going to style
your clowning it that it's probably kind
of chintzy but it's awesome stomachs
growling again assistant I miss my gum
one no honestly it won't catch trying to
make its own Rob doesn't laugh what no
same bacon you know what forget it I'm
gonna go audition to be 90 sports team
tomboy now that's not my finger that's
oh yeah that is weird my pinky I'm
recycling man please get to use me again
I decided because I didn't know how long
I knew today would be just a long day so
I said I would be the monster for today
it went really long well it looks very
detailed yeah so far yeah um and these
are these are pages - last week's
episode a top 11 that will lead into
this actually is what it is and these
are the I need some gloves camera war
and a ghostwriter I think the ones that
burn our hands I think they work they
were over there yeah so then that's
these turned inside oh wow I don't know
where to get this sweater no that's long
Chung bazaar that's okay in my wardrobe
oh that's right wait did Malcolm's for
yeah uh Disney Afternoon yeah yep solo
combination of I'm wearing a little bit
of everything
okay here's Cephas smells like Malcolm
yes the rake Lou this is it
odor a sip but then we got be like Dante
Basco going to juicy oh and just be like
I got stuff on me donut yeah somebody's
name just halfway through breakfast like
you know cuz you're so tired it just I
only hit some you think I got stuff on
my face dog yo really the funny thing is
when we're talking about this - because
rocket both Rob and I like the idea of
having like a boy in 80s boys team in
this episode and we said well what would
the monster be they got fight a monster
and we just hit reality broken and
reality monster and we're talking about
what would it look like we both had the
same idea at the end of Brazil uh Robert
De Niro gets consumed by paper and bills
and trash and stuff like that until he
you can't recognize me just totally
covered in paper and we both kind of
said at the same time I'm like yes
that's exactly
Brazil is a movie by the way yeah yeah
very good and my favorite movie Rosa Wow
yeah I've heard about it oh it's a great
yes so good it's Jonathan prices big
breakthrough role yeah
listen a bit but but but there this was
the one yeah it's not bad yeah I know
cuz I really a days - yeah like that's
gonna be a problem well you shoulda told
Malcolm he could have come in scratcher
for it just like it you know it's like
goes a half way no literally yesterday I
called up Rob and I said you know do you
want to be a nerdy kid character you
know like you know just Rob playing a
nerdy kid when you want to be the
analyst playing the very good character
and he said why don't I haven't heard
characters outfit I have the suit so
that was kind of last minute and I was
thinking but the lines were the same and
I was thinking you know what if everyone
was like a character playing a carriage
ride Julie thought me
way the black oh wow let me the black
give it and I was thinking about like
all the lines you Devils here double
costumes yeah I mean but I'll sing about
scowling hey you know I think it's
funnier if you're like you know just you
know I'm happy right then like I was
thinking like bullets what other
character did Jim play that you could
come back as and stuff you know the
sparkle Sparkle purpose so I was just
like yeah he could be queen this is if I
had you to think about me well that'd
have been fun yeah there's one of the
things like I was thinking about it's
like me a lot did still it to be enough
change there was enough time I also like
the idea like we're all trying to be
like the boy group I think it's just by
we all trying to have like you know the
boys right careful down this just happen
between here and the other room to shoot
all the suppose I'm gonna prank it oh
boy you're painting what I'm gonna
listen I sounded like Jason yeah like
Jason
yeah a pretty shirt you live that would
be funny
this isn't it but I yeah yeah people
really did enjoy the pencil head bit oh
it looks so good oh yeah I'm always so
afraid to ask for these crazy as makeup
because I'm always like cuz it's like
Jim works so hard and I'm always like I
don't wanna we always come up with such
good stuff okay you know that fun that's
a big difference between film and stage
production when I would do each stage
work when you build a set you'll only
fill this good enough to laugh for a
short period of time and it looks good
from a hundred feet away yeah in film
you've got
oh yeah like it doesn't always need to
last but needs to last you know yeah
yeah
Oh wrong I mean what I'm mostly gonna do
is you know the more watery gap to see
where it's gonna break do you know how
much tape and paper want me to fix that
uh one of my uh British buddies fans
Zander he was like oh man right Zander
um but he was asking me he was like he
didn't quite understand the little gag
where I walked back and forth across the
screen he said he thought it was funny I
know that the funny thing is that when I
wrote that it was more like he just
wanted actual scare like don't forget
about me watching it now when I edited I
realized I think I when is put together
he just always goes the wrong way
yeah if they have to go the other day
yeah
while he's so certain he's going to
leave this way right Jesus what's like
me ha ha yeah those mother is not the
greatest when it comes to directions
Minear hi she pass it on to me yeah when
I watched I thought it was just
hilarious yeah what I get it's just this
one thing I'm editing that getting it to
when he walks by again like the frame
and when the Shawn music comes in when
we see you and when he interrupts me I
mean it's like that
that took like a good half hour to
figure that out like I'll just try like
several different versions until it
finally gets a laugh because yeah it can
be as little as like you know a frame
right you can get a laugh so it's really
crazy I know it's always like I'm really
pretentious like really you know but
it's easy kind of Kenny oh my god the
reality monster was spider-man oh I
didn't bring him out of it oh I did
there's over you oh oh the boob eyes yes
why not be a twist one superhero is
always on our superhero like Batman was
always spider-man oh wow yes through
your mind whoa
we even bigger like four was Wonder
Woman a real big holy shit oh yeah right
we'll just do that all right
that's right I have a female all right
you're right female sword coming out oh
really
thank you yeah that's what I can get the
Halloween gosh yeah that's all I um sexy
Thor to me women want to be sexy forces
okay just we'll make a sexy for taurine
it all right what about the mouse no
that's the same yeah hi so this is gonna
be Dan just try your best to keep it
still I'm gonna start here I'm gonna go
Wow I'll do that for like a minute or
something and then just I like like I'm
gay it's like I blow up
I'll stand still then I'll walk out you
just keep the camera still okay got it
is there enough light on me oh yeah okay
is it too overexposed no no okay okay
ready yep and action
you
all right I'm gonna move my other chef